[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
really excited to have you guys in and
tuning in for this thoughts on warfare
episode and there's a lot to talk about
here and welcome to for those that are
new to our multidisciplinary channel
where we feature some of the greatest
minds of our time for long-form nuanced
driven thought-provoking conversations
and this episode is gonna be all about
the circumstances and the civilizations
and the different exponential
technologies that are going into all the
variables of warfare and why this is
really important to actually talk about
in all of its nuance so let's start
unpacking so the first thing that I
think is really important to look at and
I have these notes here for us to look
over as we go
is the word circumstances and relativity
because everyone wants to think that
they wouldn't be the the prison camp
guard at Auschwitz but the reality is is
that the environment around you is
extremely extremely pressing on to one's
belief structures and so it becomes very
very very difficult in order to
completely think free-thinking away from
the 99% that are trying to push you to
conform to a certain way of thought so
when it comes to all the people that
have somehow made these greedy or
corrupt decisions they have been a
product of certain circumstances that
have led them to to to have that as
their train of thought and their
decision-making
now what forces come from outside of the
planet earth and the human body and come
through the portals of the human body in
order to command these negative corrupt
forces are yet to be fully explored and
and talked about but a lot of people do
feel into them and tune into them and
talk about them all right so let's move
into so as long as we have that
understanding first and foremost they're
so crucial the circumstances and
relativity around all these things
alright so moving into the next part we
kind of started talking about them greed
and corruption and dehumanization a lot
of war stems from how we mistreat other
humans and we do humanize them from even
being human in the first place that we
think that they are lesser to then us
therefore it is OK for us to commit
these atrocious horrendous crimes like
killing them or pillaging them and so
it's things like that that have sent us
into a sort of warfare driven
understanding because we had a
limitation of resources we thought that
we had a limit of land we had a limit of
plants and animals we had a limit of
houses a limit of all these things and
limitation versus abundance is the
reason why we were in many ways killing
each other and so these limits that's
why we got greedy that's why we that's
why we dehumanized others and made it
okay to commit these atrocious crimes
against them and look at how far we've
progressed the image that you see behind
me right now is of the International
Space Station which is a collaborative
effort across the world in order for us
to be able to successfully keep that
going and that's the type of stuff that
we're gonna see in the future those
types of projects I love that project
that's one of the pinnacle ideas that
we've been able to achieve as a
collective so I hope I look forward to
seeing many more of those so you come
back to come back to the notes a lot of
a lot of what happens on the planet also
stems from mental health issues so we
have a lot of trauma that still happens
on earth so we have when when people
view other people that are addicted we
just we just posted this while I did
across my personal channels but the idea
of addiction stems from a lot of times
as in people had some sort of trauma in
their earlier years that led them to
have these addictions to power or to
fame or to materialism or to drug use or
to violence or whatever it is so a lot
of that has baked into the way that we
today live as a civilization and a lot
of that is the reasons why we have
warfare in many ways on the planet is
because of these traumatic issues that
have happened in the past how we still
again think in terms of limitation
instead of abundance it's a big key
principle in what we're discussing
alright moving on to being littered with
lost civilizations and littered with
genocides and all the millions of people
that have died so we've had a hundred
billion plus people that have lived and
died on earth before us today a hundred
billion people have lived and died
before us today and that's a lot of
people building we've talked about that
a lot
building the civilization that we have
today but tens of millions of those
people if not hundreds of millions which
we would have to do our research and
understand but it could even be hundreds
of millions of people were unjustly
murdered for limitation thoughts on
limitation instead of abundance that
they needed to pillage their land or
they needed to pillage their resources
these other people were needed to do
that they wanted to do it for more greed
for more corruption for more of their
own therefore people unjustly died and
they were not able to enjoy themselves
on this planet that they were so
graciously gifted and there's so many
lost civilizations that are here that
have passed that were completely wiped
out and that mean literally an entire
civilization not wiped out and not just
an individual and then the countless
amounts of genocides so I'm gonna touch
on this in great depth at the end but
time for peace it's time for peace but
on the way we're gonna talk about cyber
warfare because this is extremely
intense what's going on with all the
different types of warfare strategy
that exists on the planet and the
ability for such easy manipulations to
occur on to people's being is extremely
dangerous and the technology has never
been this powerful and this enabling to
make these manipulations so it's more
important now than ever to figure out
how to move forward as a civilization
when the cyber warfare age this is
pressing this is crucial and we're gonna
talk about this okay I have here I have
up and I'll show you guys my screen here
so I've brought into into the
conversation coin tell Pro cuz I want to
talk about this this is one of many of
these it's a coin sell pros a
portmanteau derived from Counter
Intelligence program and so a series of
covert and at times illegal projects
conducted by the United States FBI aimed
at surveilling infiltrating discrediting
and disrupting domestic political
organizations and so there is a there's
and there's a countless of them here the
kindness party USA anti-vietnam war
organizers activists civil rights
movement or Black Power movement MLK Jr
not a Nation of Islam and the Black
Panther Party feminists organizations
the American Indian Movement so in these
independent movements so I just I'm
bringing this up because I want people
to know that this is not just a this is
not just a single sort of of instance
that's happening today this has been
happening over time not only in the
United States but across other countries
as well where other countries are
launching these warfare programs on
their own citizenry to have a certain
agenda baked in that they want to
achieve and that agenda may be good for
just a handful of people that have the
most wealth versus the amount of people
that is again best for everyone and
that's very difficult to know what is
but so people are launching off programs
like this and they've been going on
since the beginning of time every
from manipulations like like the let's
see if we can I want us to get to this
is an interesting image for it but I
want I would definitely want to get to
this one so all the way back to the
ancient civilizations where you were
doing things like manipulating other
civilizations by sending them like the
the Trojan horse or by manipulating them
through sending spies into their into
their villages as you know and then the
spies would come back and give data and
then be able to be more easily
infiltrate the village so the or the
town in in and whatnot so this has been
going on for extremely long periods of
time and it's really important to look
over the methods here I want to I want
to show the intended effects and the
methods both so the intended effects on
organizations like coin tell pro create
a negative public image for target
groups by surveilling activists and then
releasing negative personal information
to the public that in itself is already
hugely crazy break down internal
organization by creating conflicts by
having agents exacerbate racial tensions
or send anonymous letters to try and
create conflicts create dissension
between groups by spreading rumors that
other groups were stealing money
restricted access to public resources by
pressuring nonprofit organizations to
cut off funding or material support
restrict the ability to organize
protests restrict the ability to
individuals to participate in group
activities by character assassinations
false arrests surveillance this is
extremely insane these intended effects
they're like they're like how can you
completely suppress individuals from
expressing what they desire into the
world and that is that is absolutely
nuts and it's and it's completely
mind-blowing that that is what is
currently going on
let's get that logo spinning above the
head there it is so when again when I'm
when I'm when I'm when I'm pushed to
this point of of looking at the way that
these oppressions have been going on
these structural violence has have been
going on it drives me nuts because this
is not the way that a peaceful and
humane society should be living and
collectively prospering its
way that a society for only a certain
few is is prospering at ways that it
maximizes the potential of just a couple
people that are more greedy that are
more corrupt and so it's extremely
nuanced as well because you have to
remember that there are actually things
that government agencies do that
prevents people from being assassinated
or they prevent people from being a hurt
by the masses so no most people will
have a binary stance on this and I I
definitely skewed towards the side of
figuring out the right resource flows
and infrastructures for maximizing
everyone's potential but in terms of the
government actually doing some things
right in order to retain some sort of
sense of peace or equilibrium or or
people just not being obliterated and
dying by the masses they do some of that
right so it's not to be completely
binary here that the government
definitely does some of the things that
are right but that at the same time when
you look at this it also becomes crazy
and then this is where we're gonna go
get into cyber war because the methods
that they're using are again look at
this eight infiltration agents and
informers did not merely spy on
political activists the remain purpose
was to discredit disrupt and negatively
redirect an action their very presence
served to undermine trust and scare off
potential supporters the FBI and police
exploited the sphere to smear genuine
activists as agents psychological
warfare the FBI and police use myriad
dirty tricks to undermine progressive
movements bad jacketing create
suspicions about targeted activists
sometimes lethal consequences harassment
via the legal system illegal force
undermine public opinion there's so many
of these methods right and now I want to
direct us to this which is not only were
we talking about the different countries
in the world and how the different
countries around the world do this to
like China Russia the area of the Middle
East area of Europe South America and
Africa because they do this differently
with their own greedy and corrupt
leadership's that sometimes they think
they're doing something right and they
may be making it
that people can live more peacefully but
at the same time other times they're
doing it to thwart off a political
organization that is attempting to
potentially do something like remove a
structural violence all right moving on
to deep fakes this is extremely
important we've had people like dr.
roaming at Polsky on our show and AI
safety and security researcher and deep
fakes are an immensely important deal
because we're currently seeing what
could be the next sort of jump in
propaganda on the internet that people
can't distinguish ibly tell what's real
and what's not which is a big issue
because when next time you see a video
of someone you may not even know if that
video is actually really them speaking
or not this could be the president of a
country this could even be just the
leader of a very large company and so
that's extremely challenging because it
completely that disinformation
completely changes the way that we
perceive what we thought to be true or
not so that's a major point so is just
psycho metrics and targeted propaganda
in general being able to analyze but
through even just a couple hundred likes
that you can analyze the way that you
can predict the way that someone's going
to vote or behave and so that way you
can send them targeted propaganda and
these types of studies have been going
on for a while now for a couple decades
where you can just psychometric ly pick
based on ocean the the Big Five
personality traits that you can just
just like that you can know how someone
is gonna behave when you send them a
certain propaganda bio and neural
warfare is extremely important we talked
about this a lot during the during that
we're not ready yet for transhumanism
episode because when you have things
like these extremely exponential
technologies that can absolutely
obliterate civilizations
excuse me or give a tremendous amount of
power to those that are malevolent
that it's really important to slow down
and think and actually figure out how to
best progress ethically with those
technologies and again we've we talked
about some great depth but we move on to
things like drone and robot warfare and
again we see so
much of that potential malevolence that
we have to slow down and ethically think
about how to collaborate together as a
planet moving forward
centralized versus decentralized warfare
this is very interesting there may be a
period of time where we see centralized
organizations try and hurt decentralized
organizations because they don't want to
lose their power meanwhile decentralized
power I think is going to erupt around
the planet and we're on our way out here
on the thoughts on warfare episode I'm
really excited for the role of youth
especially Generation Z as they evolve
because I think they are going to be the
ones that help us figure out what how to
move forward peacefully how to move
forward with a push for a spiritual
Communion and I think that that
spiritual Communion and for many people
is a practice of just believing in
something greater than themselves that
transcends their human body whether that
be through a believing in a deity or
believing in a meditation practice or
psychedelic practice that there is a
spiritual with the communion with the
infinite and then it's going to be
incredible seeing more and more people
become actualized in that in that
bottom-up revolution I'm going to talk
about that right here on the way out
we'll have coherence with energy with
earth energy and way the eradication of
greed corruption violence and increase
in accountability so the revolution has
to happen one of two ways pretty much
top-down or bottom-up I've talked about
this before that you can try and do
something like micro dos the United
Nations General Assembly which is again
people usually aren't ready for some
sort of spiritual like they would
definitely not a lot of them would not
be ready for that sort of spiritual
growth and so they might actually have a
really poor experience because of that
so it's really important to know who's
ready and when they're ready and how
they're ready so a bottom-up experience
where people have at their own time sort
of in the lower rungs of the
socio-economic statuses they have went
through processes of spiritual
actualization and they can more easily
guide the future trajectory of
elective conscious progress on the on
civilization damn this stuff is so
interestingly difficult to actually
speak about I'm glad that I'm going for
it I think so you can check this out
top down is much more less likely to
happen there's too much too many of
those pressures and unearned wisdoms and
there's too much old money involved and
so how do we match actualize and
maximize the potential of young people
to build these new resource flows and
frameworks and so that's where I'll end
the episode on the thoughts on warfare
you got to remember the relativity of
all these things that war in the past
has been going on for since we've
started as a civilization and in order
for us to transcend war in order for us
to move forward with true love and
harmony and peace that we have to have a
deep sense of empathy for each other we
have to have a deep sense of removing
the structural violence is of removing
the evil parasitic energies of overtly
greedy and corrupt people and
corporations and governments and we can
do that together that is not impossible
to do but it's gonna require a lot of
work and a lot of time and a lot of
spiritual hustle for us and a lot of
economic framework redesigning and so
that's all up to us and that's up to us
to work with the young people to be able
to do so thanks for tuning in to this
episode on thoughts on warfare I greatly
appreciate it I'm Allen Sokka and the
host of simulation and check out our
channel check out our other videos we
would love to hear from you in the
comments below let us know your thoughts
about how to move forward with this join
our public Telegram where we have these
thoughts the links in the bio of this
video also build the future go and
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love and I'll see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]